maxime plus amour que vous vous savez
quelle est la fréquence des rapports
sexuels français ait admis parce
qu'apparemment commun il n'y a que le
set par mois à 8,7 pour moi ouais quatre
week-ends devra par week-end qu'a vous
voit dès lors il tue peu de poids dans
le week end
bah oui et alors alors là je suis nommée
when 1,8 voilà huit qui dit mieux
ouvrant à castaldi barème et lui c'est
normal il a tué une femme quoi castaldi
battu et je vous dis pas de suite par
mois ouais mais au mois de février mais
mis à part une minimum une fois par jour
mais quelle femme ne jamais sortir le
fusil chargé ses classes elle a dû des
hôpitaux la pas confiance à mes canons
[Rires]